I want you to mate places that I want
you to look on this website okay
the first is let's get a view and ideal
basics hope you click on that okay now
when you get there what you'll find is
this page and this picture is really
helpful actually it shows it gives you a
really good sense of all in a normal
house what kind of things a man looking
for with this on the side what I advise
is you have a look at this checklist
pick it now and if you're like me then
the first thing your experience is you
just get sort of overwhelmed by my
goodness number one is sorry I went to
the picture with that this is a big deal
there's a lot it is and number two
there's a lot of specialized language
that maybe you've never heard of before
never had to interact with even I've
ever had to interact with so you're
going to have to do a bit of hunting
okay so let's just have a quick scroll
down I'll tell you what I mean
scroll Scroll scroll okay so here is any
number what we're talking about right
you can see here these are the kinds of
things that contribute to your basic
certification or not certification do
you have rain water tanks and storm
water tanks do you have a reticulated
alternative water supply where the
reticulated alternative water supply a
lot of these phrases this by the way is
that reusable world right so can you use
water that you've collected for things
like watering your garden and that kind
of thing by the way this is crazy yeah
if you don't know what it means
it just means drinkable oh my is a safer
drinking Sydney water is incredibly high
quality as compared to a lot of places
in the world
so not all water is drinkable
you can see this what is water used know
kind of being some places are big enough
that they have a private damnit
obviously that affects your boobs
significant for instance and my previous
school they had a pretty big dam and so
most of the water in the gardens came
from that rather than through yeah
the pups that are drinkable water is not
a waste that or putting that on a farm
as you keep going you may go to things
like this far in a way the biggest use
of electricity is going to be on
controlling heat right because we like
our air temperatures to be comfortable
so that's why they call this thermal
comfort so what I'm going to ask you to
do is to go through this page my page so
I think we have to do 308 it's not a
huge long document but I want you to
have underneath there what that scissors
does dot was funny about right how I
want you to identify those issues you've
just mentioned a few of them but
underneath here what you say what what
has to be paid attention to
even something like look at this this
should not just that man conditioning on
what how do you write we mentioned
before things like window is have a look
at what nice is insulation right a few
years ago you guys are too young to
remember but there was a big grant from
the government to put insulation a
pattern into like your ceilings and that
kind of thing because they were trying
to address issues of sustainability if
you've got to inter encounter you
obviously don't need to use as much air
conditioning will here in Carroll is the
thing with the company mr. Lovings they
try to put all that in there but I
didn't realize until about three years
ago thank you um really for doing your
yeah well there were heaps of problems
when this big government grant came it
was billions of dollars so everyone is
suddenly number one looking for places
to install and number two realizing oh
wait I could probably do this like I can
buy this stuff from a wholesaler and
then this ballin house is not that bad
not that difficult but a lot of places
McCain corners and a lot of the actual
materials they use we're highly in time
rule which is obviously one of the
safety problems because you know
everyone wanted to do it there was not
enough regulation to make sure everyone
who was doing it was doing it safely
using asbestos those company anyhow my
point is just to help you identify these
are the kind of issues we're talking
about what is this about this idea
what's this there this is about like
justjust look we hardly ever think about
this right do you think or what this is
before your structure is going to lose a
lot of heat or is going to retain a lot
of heat right think of that in your
house what them we those are like how
many windows you have and how big they
are
right so now going over here on the
website there's what one thing I wanted
to point out to you let me just see if I
find it
okay
the last thing that's important for you
underneath your car I want you to have
listed out those issues such as thermal
concept which means Albert you know the
structure and how it loses heat or will
retain heat but that an important bit is
when you go to the website you say using
the Vantage assessment tool how does it
work right how does it work that's good
click on Nancy have it already okay I
want you to read this really carefully
this is actually it's so much math that
goes into this which you don't have to
know yourself but you need to know that
there's mass going on underneath because
eyes are just spit on number you know
when it is number come from and a comes
from place like places like this have a
look at this mineral sentence this is
really important resource demand how
many people are there what kind of
technology are in there and how much
there is what climate your environment
is do you live in a valley sort of area
or does yours is yours quite flat where
you apply where you learn that makes a
really big difference to the climate
that you're going to experience and then
down the bottom here talks about how how
does it calculate baseball and if you
have a single drilling is it something
that can attach to another house all
those kinds of things effective okay so
what I'm going to give you is about
maybe 15 to 20 minutes to sort of work
your way around this website if you want
some useful information there lots of
phrases that you've maybe never heard of
which I want you to look up and suddenly
this is here I might identify those
issues I'm going to give you some
Russian after ok